hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
I'm Doug Walker and why the hell you
wearing a wig well I just wanted to have
amazing hair like they did in last voice
which we're watching today I actually
brought you one get it that this doesn't
work you'll pick Donny Osmond this is
Tamra's never seen and today we are
watching lost boys for the first time uh
I should point out I also have not seen
this probably goes without saying have
you heard anything about this movie I
just know they're vampires yeah that's
all I know - I know Joe Schumacher
directed it and it's supposed to be one
of the good ones like you know he's done
some bad films he's in some okie films
he's done some good ones this is
supposed to be good so I'm I'm excited
I'm very curious I get comments all the
time for people saying but I should
watch this so I'm glad that you haven't
seen it either
yeah will you snap with me okay good one
- haha
[Music]
Michael Michael Mike that's the movie
Julie they say Michael a thousand F he
goes he's like an evil elmer fudd feels
like they need some ADR and they didn't
have time so they just put that over and
over and over it was this was a boy
world
hilarious weird as hell so funny yeah
this is like 80s cheese but also like
and kind of dark and weird it's like
five different things put together that
normally don't go together but because
there's that 80's cheese it like really
really works yeah it's like part horror
film part comedy part monster squad part
interview with a vampire there's a lot
of aspects to it that like if they
didn't all come together like that it
just wouldn't work
yeah like good reason like if I just
read this script I'd be like bullshit
I'm not making this but because it's
just so strange and just so in its own
weird world or a weird couple of worlds
it's just super fun there are so many
moments when something would happen and
we like what it's like legit
funny is legit kind of cool legit dorky
legit really interesting legit well-made
legit terribly made but it it all goes
together it's just whole crazy and it's
all ablaze the costumes were amazing the
sets were amazing and the characters
were amazing the grandfather the great
fun the yet we don't have spoilers right
yeah the godly vampire the head vampire
thing and that legit shock to me yeah
like I couldn't believe I actually fell
for that don't you get to his corey
feldman
yeah Cody is weird okay he's a kid in
this why is he trying to do a low voice
the hold side but he cracks me up every
single time there's many different ways
the vampire die sometimes you implode or
explode but they'll always should to
take you with them it's like I don't
know what you're doing but I add orange
yeah
I love where you're going with it even
like the scenes I thought like I
wouldn't like like when they're trying
to prove that the one dude is the lead
vampire looks like he's not like well
that didn't fit that's like the one
moment that doesn't work but it does
work it's even funnier so okay it opens
to this family moving to this boardwalk
California town and you see the vampires
out of merry-go-round because of course
but thank god there's a cop on that Mary
girl just waiting there in case
somebody's trying to start trouble on
this merry-go-round and then you see
this hair metal band this like rock band
do you remember that very very Joel
Schumacher just the guy just totally
shirtless built as hell covered in
something wet yeah just like wrap the
log yeah with like the long hair and
stuff it just is so that was maybe my
favorite part one of the scenes I liked
is that when the cop is about to get
attacked it's actually really clever
filmmaking where it's a it's this aerial
shot it's looking down at him and then
him walking normal and stuff and then he
looks up at the aerial shot he's like ah
and he runs away it's like oh that was
the vampires point of view like you
didn't know it to like you exactly what
shit kind of good filmmaking there it
was yeah yeah that was that was really
there were some really good shots and
then like we noticed some not really
good shot yeah but but again it's in
this movie I give it a pass because it's
so entertaining I believe it all
something Schumacher does a lot is he'll
do like backward shots instead like
you'll play footage backwards which I do
too like I said I can't complain but
there's one where it's like you see them
going into like the cave it's like their
point of view and then later when they
leave in the cave they just play back or
is it just like okay again time money I
get it but you see the water going
backwards it's like you could have cut
before that that's just lazy which is
it's always fun to watch films with
people who like make film I would have
never noticed that okay we're watching
up just like okay that's the shot they
did before but playing it backwards and
then will we see the waves going
backwards I'm like ah you don't know
this cuz you never watched Gilmore Girls
Oh
the grandpa from Gilmore Girls is the
head vampire in this film which is
hilarious to me here was amazing and
like we said when he becomes the head
vampire and it's revealed he still has
his like delightful voice like very cool
calm and collected yeah like when
they're like you're the lead the head
vampire he's like it seemed like there
were two movies constantly fighting for
attention one was kind of like an
awkward moving in just little kids
getting used to town and then just like
this teenage angst vampire movie and
they were so different that of course
they went together every time you went
back and forth I'm always like oh I
wonder what's going out with the vampire
yeah it goes back to them oh what's
going on with the weird family it goes
back to them so it like Consulate's this
perfect seesaw of oddness yeah so Corey
Feldman is trying to teach the younger
brother how to like kill vampires
meanwhile the older brother Michael he's
hanging out with all like the vampires
for a girl which is not worth it but
anyways this girl yeah what's her name
again
hey I like all our lines I like this I
get just a heads up any time you watch a
Schumacher movie the romance is never
between the boy and girl it's always
between either two boys possibly more
and clearly this is between like yeah
and Kiefer Sutherland and the other main
boy they had the real romance I loved it
so the younger brother finds out that
Michael is a vampire and he's like way
more annoyed than he is scared you're a
goddamn vampire I told them that you're
like a werewolf but could be werewolf
man dork
Oh also everyone gave Twilight so much
crap the film came out because the
vampires were sparkly but the vampires
literally bleed glitter they bleed
glitter in this film yeah we're just
like oh so that's that's where I started
and of course if they're saying well
it's gonna do vampire sparkling it's
gonna be Twilight and Joel Schumacher
Schumacher did a lot better
the baby rules are kind of weird in this
light yeah first of all I guess if you
drink their blood you become a vampire
like vampires Oh believe em but she
wasn't believe vampire there's a bunch
of different ways vampires die why I
heard that my it's like okay one light
falls into a bathtub filled with garlic
and in holy water that they just told
from a church which is my favorite and
he's like okay he's melting he's three
into a skillet okay fair enough but felt
like the sinks are exploding like the
kitchen is dripping with blood and
they're just all blowing I'm like this
makes no goddamn sense but I loved it it
was so all the plumbing in the house was
just leaking blood oh it's exploded
everywhere it's like an evil dead movie
yes yes I didn't follow it but I I loved
it cool as hell yeah and then also the
second vampire death was amazing the
stereo and then his head explodes
yeah buddy stereo and I also loved the
mom is so sweet in this where's Diane we
she's from Edward Scissorhands and she
always plays this role but she plays it
so well and she's so like a boy for all
these vampire movies where they're
always like again in Twilight like
you're a vampire no or keep her Saarland
you're a vampire no I mean that dude I
was legit surprised if I thought he was
a vampire oh my god the twist yes oh my
god it's everything that doesn't
normally quite go together somehow going
together perfectly yeah I was saying
before if you show me this movie and you
told me this dude's gonna direct like a
Batman movie I'd be like gulp this
cannot lose this will be amazing this
will be just like the Burton films or
you know that this will be a ton of fun
it'll look great and no this is like
straight-up 80s to me like when I
started this series and you and Rob
especially we're like oh man 80s films
are just batshit crazy this is what I
imagined in my head and some of them do
live up to it but this is just like oh
this is kind of the exact build I want
to see like when it's he lost boys and
vampires 80s and crazy Joe Schumacher
except real
working towards awesome good like Jeff
it's the crazy awkward fun but it's like
really cool um I get this that I was not
disappointed in the lease yeah I love
this movie well next we're watching
legends mmm so it'll be as fun right I'm
sure thank you so much for watching
we'll catch you guys next week bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you